oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding me
ah where's the door
uhh
I hate the sound
[Music]
[Applause]
thanking God we are always right
it's great
that's not disturbing it at all the good
thing is in this game
[ __ ] [ __ ] some [ __ ]
[Music]
I know what the [ __ ] I was mother like
she was the most beautiful creature ever
to be raised as well I can remember she
looks like no matter how hard I try her
beautiful thing to see
there's such memory to our minds it
would be too much here they're here
Oh what I'm stuck whoa shovel is back
all these images are so deserving
Thank You game for giving you all in
this they give you the latter but no
more like thank you talk about a laugh
in your face
[Music]
Herbert all right yeah compacted the
consulate and they said they will send
you the permits you need for visiting
Algeria I wish you good luck on your
search and that your findings will come
at a lower price and mine
I am at loss with my studies my daughter
has become distraught and distant I did
a little loser to control her behavior
yet I believe the very notion of my
observation has made her this way my
scientific in a difference to our test
has not left her with an indifferent
opinion she finds my lack of reaction
disappointing she judges me and most
important herself by the resultant with
us the reason I have had trouble finding
any consolation your character is
because she tries different approaches
to provoke me and her actions only
becomes more and more deserving
yesterday I lost myself I scolded her
she was terrified and humiliated
it saddens me greatly to bring my
studies to a close without seeing into
the end but I can no longer justify my
research I have to mend my relationship
but it all made sense he ah
we all appreciate submit she actually I
think I lost everyone is comforted by
the casualty of Adak it gives some
rationale of a grand plan and we may be
able to bounce the inner workings of
this perfect universe you see his wife
had died while giving her his son that
is why he was
no that makes no [ __ ] sense at all
right why are you walking so [ __ ]
slow Jesus right like what he has to say
I just hope the zombie doesn't appear
whatever you want to call it [ __ ]
thing yes I concur it's my cabinet
recording you will figure it out all by
yourself did anyone survive the doctor
supreme what you should really reflect
on these past events and consider what
they meant to you what you've learned
about I'm fine without
it's all good ever hear me what will
that perfect we're a free
we must hurry it's not stay alive yellow
king shell
Oh
Seifer the trial I guess that's what I'm
doing through the games I like that they
connected the first game I mean amnesia
the Dark Descent this is so disturbing
I have no oil in my sanity except aside
anything
I am emerging kami
oh how this was I'm crying the
characters crying
play ball it will be again it's coming
[Music]
I don't like this
Oh
able to go on
what I do
what yeah
what the
don't get that thing
come on
okay
[Music]
am i doing
doing well the [ __ ] walls
you must be joking
[Music]
get up it's not over you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes it is
I survived because I kill all the people
this was the best one yet
yes so elaborate it's just too much
enough of this get up Jesse
isn't it all covered in chain such light
was never meant for me
what
I really should keep this door locked
oh I get it
oh yes I'm quite all right
is everything ready for tonight
the goose is ready any minute now the
guests should be arriving within the
hour
they are not hear voices from downstairs
uh I certainly hope not
this room really me yes Billy Clarice
[Music]
that was really good that was a really
good deal see
holy [ __ ] scan the crap out of me I bet
I totally fail like I say none of the
people I'm not even sure if you can but
I'm finding the way there's no way I'm
retaking but it wasn't that wasn't
really awesome actually
[ __ ] Leah makes such awesome games I'm
so jealous I guess this was kind of
short let's play him it wasn't you'll
see after all which is good because I
didn't have much time anyway
but
thank you for watching I guess I'm gonna
stay until the credits but I don't have
anything to say so
[Music]
oh look at this I'm Guitar Hero for
Nintendo DS it's really awesome
[Music]
laughter awkward silence
nothing to show nothing will
GLaDOS really special thanks to GLaDOS
and the earth
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] did it
I thought for sure I was gonna die like
so many times and this is gonna be the
most painfully the playthrough to watch
ever but I guess I did okay and I guess
this game doesn't want me to go to the
credit I mean oh there it is alright
that's it
have a good one and have fun this thing
at the vagina hole and all season
bye-bye
you